financial relief could finally be on the
way for millions of americans congress
passed a nearly 900 billion dollar
coveted package
late last night after months of fighting
when the president signs it it will
allow
600 checks to go out by the end of the
year the bill includes
a lot more than just covet relief take a
look at this
we want to show you what it looks like
on paper a whopping
5 600 pages long can you believe that
wow goodness
many lawmakers said they had just hours
to read it
before voting or perhaps just skim
through it really nancy cordes is on
capitol hill nancy good morning
good morning despite that last minute
attempt this
big relief bill did pass both houses of
congress
overwhelmingly the senate vote was 92-6
showing that there was plenty of support
for a large stimulus package
all along now the bill is headed to the
president's desk
just in time for christmas in the
literal
11th hour congress acted late last night
the motion to concur has agreed to to
bring relief
to beleaguered americans 600 dollars
could start arriving in people's bank
accounts between christmas
and new year's a promise from president
trump's
treasury secretary people are going to
see this money the beginning of next
week
so it's very fast but it was a slow road
to get here
as businesses shuttered congress
sputtered
over how to help the nearly 11 million
unemployed americans
nearly double the jobless numbers from
before the pandemic
we've assembled another historic
bipartisan rescue package
democrats wanted a bill three times
larger
today is a good day but it is certainly
not the end of the story
it cannot be the end of the story the
stimulus checks will go to individuals
who make less than
75 thousand dollars a year or couples
making less than a hundred fifty
thousand
six hundred more per child means a
family of five will get
three thousand dollars i would like them
bigger but they are
significant there's also 25 billion
to help renters 13 billion for food
stamps and child nutrition benefits
and 10 billion for child care to help
parents get back to work
plus 300 a week jobless benefits for the
next two and a half
months the top republican in congress
insisted
it's enough for now it's not too little
too late it's directly targeted at
exactly what the country needs
democrats agreed to the shorter time
frame for benefits in the hopes that
they will have a
stronger hand in another round of
negotiations in 2021
that's when they will have a democrat in
the white house and they're hoping
their party will control the senate
jamie yeah we'll have to wait for that
nancy between this bill and the larger
government spending bill i read that
lawmakers would have had to read 10
pages a minute
do they even know what they voted on at
this point
you know they knew the broad outlines
jamie but there's no way they were going
to be able to
read in any kind of detailed fashion
through that enormous pair of bills
before
they had to vote on them so there were
some extraneous measures
that ended up in these two pieces of
legislation let me give you
some examples first of all there was one
provision
that would make some illegal streaming
a felony and would create two new
smithsonian museums dedicated to latinos
and women that is something that
actually had
a lot of support the bill also makes
business meals
tax deductible and it includes tax
breaks for
craft brewers and distillers and even
race horse owners now obviously few of
these measures are related to the
pandemic but a fact of life here on
capitol hill is that at the end of the
year when congress is scrambling to get
out of town
they will often slip some of these
measures into a bill
that has to pass i don't see a lot of
and pop stores on that list nancy thank
you